[Music]
you may have been rejected by your
family because you're lgbt so our
thanksgiving celebration is a way to
celebrate our family that we build here
at the center and for everyone to have
the opportunity to be supported during
the holidays
i'm nico tortorella i'm an actor an
activist and a firm believer that our
differences actually make us stronger
i'm on a journey with ikea to meet real
people and discover the diverse and
spectacular ways they celebrate the
holidays
[Music]
maybe you celebrate thanksgiving with
your extended family and maybe you
celebrate thanksgiving with your chosen
family like the people at our first stop
i'm david mariner and i'm the executive
director of the dc center for the lgbt
community welcome to our fifth annual
thanksgiving celebration
everyone comes with their own
experiences and traditions and customs
we need to acknowledge not just their
lgbt identities
but their whole self
my name is nicholas mawanda i'm
originally from uganda but right now
living in washington dc the dc center
helps lgbtq plus asylum seekers and
refugees who are no longer safe in their
own countries
it's common place for someone to be
kicked out of their home
in uganda for lgbt it's common place for
someone to be disowned by their family
this year the asylum seekers and
refugees are bringing a traditional dish
from their home country to share with
the entire center nick is preparing
rolexes
it's called rolex in uganda too yes and
it's just the way we roll it
it is really important for me that i
share the beautiful thing about my
culture we celebrate brotherhood
sisterhood in forms of sharing
knife is on the inside or the outside
knife is on the inside
hi everyone i'm tamara my pronouns are
she her and hers
my tradition actually has been coming to
the dc center
to volunteer and give back
i think when we go around the table and
we share the traditions that we have
around the holidays we all are a little
bit more connected and we understand how
similar we all are my favorite holiday
tradition is eating
and
second only by being around my friends
and family i grew up in nebraska and we
always had a thanksgiving dinner like
not too different than this
i would love to share the good things
about my tradition people won't learn
unless you share
it's part of bringing cross cultures
it's part of learning about each other
appreciating each other
[Music]
we celebrate differently but maybe
that's what makes us all so beautiful
[Music]
it's more important today than ever to
show up for the holidays as yourself
share your tradition because the more
that we see the more we believe the more
we respect and the more we love